even though there are fears that kovid
is set for a comeback this winter
boris johnson is urging britain to get
back to work but for the millions of us
who have young children this is often
easier said
than done
at this nursery in south london many of
the parents are relieved that once again
they can get on with their working lives
safe in the knowledge that their
children are being well cared for
she was so excited to go back to nursery
she would
and when she saw all our teachers on the
zoom call she was
like screaming out she was really
excited to come back
she was very she loves nursery how
important is it for
working parents to have nurseries open
very important because without the
nurses we can't go to work
and that's the bottom line and the
nurseries
and sometimes it's a safe place for
children and it's for them to interact
and have fun with their friends and
you know it's a nice place nurseries
regardless if you're working or not
working
nurseries are nice for children to come
into but with the infection rates rising
in some areas and the government
imposing more restrictions on gatherings
there are fears that the respite for
busy parents might be short-lived
are you worried that nurseries might
close again i am yes because i was
actually at the point where i was
starting to think about looking for work
again
um but if that happens obviously it will
you know be
able to work because i'll have two tiny
children to look after again
i know a lot of people are worried about
you know another rise of infection
coming up and what that could look like
as schools are phased back in
um so yeah obviously it's praying on our
minds it's something that we're you know
really concerned about because we're
just starting to kind of
get some sense of routine back to the
children this nursery is run by a
company whose chief executive
is proud that she managed to keep going
throughout the covid lockdown
providing child care for essential
workers a lot of our parents work in the
nhs
so we started to think about how many
nurses we could keep open and so
eventually
we um we ended up with 15 open the whole
time
and how hard is it to safely distance in
a nursery well we didn't socially
distance in the nursery we created our
own bubbles before anyone came up with
the idea of bubbles because children
need children need comfort
and they uh then they're human they need
touch
and it's part of their learning so there
was no issue there and i think once
parents realized that there was going to
be no issue there they were
far more relaxed can you imagine you're
a busy doctor in the nhs
you want to leave your child somewhere
safe you do not want to be going away
worrying that your child isn't going to
be picked up our cuddles are cared for
so no we put all of that out of their
minds
and interestingly throughout lochton no
child got sick
and no staff member got sick so how
difficult is it for nurseries now
it's terrifying because nursery is run
on occupancy
and our occupancy pays for our staff
costs and
the contribution we get from the
government which is often determined as
free is not free we have to subsidize
that
as well and because we're a social
enterprise we subsidize a large number
of children who would otherwise not be
able to afford nursery
there are some real risks around though
so there's an organization called sea
that does quite a lot of our research
and they have said that they anticipate
around 37 to 40 percent of
nurseries particularly in areas of
deprivation you know who are living very
much on the edge
so 40 are at risk of closure of closure
yeah
and what would another lockdown mean for
nurseries i think it financially would
kill a lot of us
i mean i really do and i do wonder why
the government doesn't appreciate the
fact that we were the fourth emergency
service during lockdown
it took them a long time to clap for us
you know the
this 76 percent of parents work and they
don't have extended networks and kinship
and stuff and you might be working from
home but
we all know it's very hard with a small
child and also
i guess parents who rely on grandparents
for additional childhood
support can't happen and then what about
the children themselves
they're entitled to access to their own
nurseries they love their nurseries they
thrive in their nurseries they you know
they need it for their learning and
that's not to say parents aren't great
with their children but
there are other things i can't tell you
how many parents said to me they hadn't
realized
just how much friendships mattered to
children as young as two
and how even though we did zoom and we
did home learning and we did digital
this that and the other
the the warmth and the engagement and
the experience you've probably just seen
this morning
was missing through that digital lens
and that's really significant
and what's really sad is that so many
children from poorer families haven't
come back
they've been really terrorized i think
they live on the edge anyway in terms of
poverty
poverty is like really are sort of on
the rise
and when you talk to those parents which
we did and we provided meal packs and we
provided all sorts of additional things
they really were terrified that if
anything went wrong they're very
narrow sort of scary you know boundary
would tip into disaster for them so what
can the government do
the government needs to really
acknowledge the sector
they need to acknowledge that we are
part of their national infrastructure
and as such we should be funded
correctly
should they're already before lockdown
we were 662 million pounds
shortfall throughout the contribution of
offering the 30 hours and and not
um and so the government needs to have a
very clear statement
that they value it and that's the model
that they've got at the moment
maybe it's not the greatest model
because it's very mixed maybe they need
to spend some time looking at that
if the economy is to recover from
lockdown then parents need to be able to
get back to work
but right now that's easier said than
done many can no longer rely on
grandparents or after school clubs that
are still closed
thousands of nurseries are at risk of
going bust and with rising infections
another lockdown could send them over
the edge